bonjour à l'us je m'appelle bêtise d'une
chaude de ma famille et entendantes
l'étui professionnels de la petite
enfance et moi je m'appelle germaine je
suis entendantes je n'ai aucune famille
sourde
je suis également professionnels de la
petite enfance art thérapeute et
formatrice en langue des signes d'aidé
nous avons suivi la formation de monica
compagnie
l'initiatrice du concept de l'atelier bd
s'il ya la mère de l'allant de tin bébé
grâce à mika on s'est rencontré et là
c'était évident qu'on devait animer des
ateliers ensemble alors on a créé les
ateliers l'île aux cygnes l'île aux
cygnes
j'ai surtout travaillé avec les enfants
qui ne sont copiés de l'apal en langue
des signes
nous avons marqué les enfants se
montrent attentifs quand on ne l'a pas
l'enseignant vous savez les visualise la
langue française et la reproduite en
communication gestuelle précise la
langue de signes n'est pas dans langage
mais elle est bien une langue
pourquoi alors twh et sourde
tu signes avec les enfants entendants
parce que c'est ma langue naturelle
''j'ai toujours fumier et parler avec
les enfants dans montre les mots à
l'enfant peut le rassurer les plus
profond de lui même
edward herman pourquoi keating avec les
enfants atteints d'un évent ceux qui
m'ont a donné goût se sont peut-être mes
origines martiniquaises et italiennes
mais depuis que je suis toute petite
j'aime observer les adultes pour
comprendre comment il parle comment ils
s'expriment comment leur communication
verbale s'exprimer qu'est ce qu'elle
raconte
et puis en fait j'ai très vite observé
et remarqué que les adultes étaient
capables d'exprimer des choses
différentes de leurs propres mots alors
je suis devenue comédienne pour
comprendre et puis art thérapeute pour
aider et aujourd'hui je suis
professionnelle de la petite enfance
formatrice je travaille avec des enfants
leurs parents et des professionnels de
la petite enfance pour que ces adultes
développe et fasse évoluer leur qualité
de relations et communications avec les
enfants pour moi l'objectif des signes
associés au mot c'est de permettre de
mettre en cohérence la communication non
verbale et la communication verbale
c'est pour parler vrai vraiment aux
enfants tu sais betty tu connais plein
d'entendants tu travailles avec une
entendante et tu sais que nous les
entendants on est capable de dire les
choses comme ça je suis très contente
ou alors ou alors elles sont le fait
beaucoup avec les enfants je suis pas du
tout énervé alors arrête tout
si tu es prime quelque chose de
différent
l'enfant ne peut pas comprendre
même moi je prends un enfant le mieux
c'est de tenir précédemment et 1 on
réfute l'expression pascal dupuis truste
depuis lé traité
je suis en colère les émotions
s'expriment clairement il n'y a ni
détours ni faux semblants arbres se voit
se dit 100 ans
et ça ça vient stimuler le phénomène de
représentation mentale parce que les
mots deviennent palpables visuelle elle
phénomène de représentation mentale
c'est ce qui permet de penser les choses
de les imaginer de l'est rêver avant de
les dire et de les réaliser
si je vous dis
le mot pomme qu'est ce qui se passe dans
vos têtes
comment aller votre pomme à la ronde
elle est comment verte croquante aller
comme en tapotant rouge
elle est rouge enfin bon c'est peut-être
influencé la robe rouge la pomme rouge
la pomme de blanche neige vous l'avez en
tête puisque je vous dis
bon bref chacun sa représentation sa
pomme suivant le goût que vous avez de
la pomme la culture que vous en avez
l'expérience même que vous avez de la
pomme pour l'enfant c'est pareil ils
voient la pomme il à goutte il en a
l'expérience il se représente la pom mes
pommes c'est facile c'est un objet c'est
concret maintenant je vous dis partir
revenir travail là les représentations
sont plus floues l'image est plus
abstraite n'avait pas ce que ces mots-là
s'intègre au fil de l'expérience de vie
plus ou moins heureuses et nous dans
notre quotidien professionnel
on voit souvent à notre quotidien
professionnel de petite enfance on voit
souvent cette situation là au moment de
la séparation du matin entre eux les
parents et l'enfant
alors je vous la fait recette plus
facile ne me regarde pas là il voit pas
j'en profitais pour partir parce qu'à
chaque fois qu'ils me voient ils
pleurent h
je pars discrètement de vie conseille de
ne pas partir comme t'as pas que
l'enfant qui va se sentir abandonnés le
mieux c'est de lui expliquer tout temps
tignon maman part au travail
elle revient des chargés d'histoire dieu
peut avoir quand betty vous assignez
plus parler en fait c'est ça qu'on fait
on donne le choix à l'enfant de
comprendre l'adulte dans ces signaux
dans ses mots et avant de parler l'an
tous les enfants montrent du doigt
kolonick avec leur langage non verbal
leur gestuelle leur expressivité leurs
cris leurs pleurs certains signes signé
c'est respecter l'enfant dans sa qualité
propre de communication
vous connaissez la lande et il est il
naturel les attendant vous connaissez
vos cils naturels commandite veux dormir
elle connaît suffisamment mangé
ouais dévorer boire ne lésine apporte
une qualité des changes de plaisir du
partage et de la complicité plus
d'interactions car pour signer un enfant
on doit se mettre à sa hauteur face à
face de l'oeil à l'oeil on ne signe pas
tout la phrase c'est comme si on tue
line les mots clés de la phrase par
exemple on va se promener en forêt mais
tes chaussures et ton manteau montrer
les mots à l'enfant lui permet de mieux
comprendre
l'adulte et de mieux comprendre les mots
et du coup de mieux les dire
l'enfant apprend vite à signer il
regarde c'est facile alors que la parole
mais beaucoup plus de temps à se
développer
justement souvent une question nous est
posée à betty à moi peut-être que
certains d'entre vous se la posent aussi
aujourd'hui alors je la pose est
clairement un béti et betty
est ce que la langue des signes pour les
enfants entendants retarde la parole
bien sûr que non
au contraire certaines îles la parole et
le langage de l'enfant l'enfant se sent
mieux pour compris ça calme les
frustrations et les parasites 5 et des
et ça développe la tension ni duel alors
nous déjà on signe pas pour que les
enfants signe parce qu'ils le feront
s'ils le veulent s'ils en ont envie
on signe pour que les adultes développe
et améliore leur qualité de
communication avec les jeunes enfants
je vais bien legend de yuen tu say you
when you when un an
il est séché son assistante maternelle
qui a appris la langue des signes bébé
et puis à midi les dents une tablée de
sept personnes dans un brouhaha des
conversations ça parle partout et un
moment donné où m il lève le doigt
et il fait ce signe là alors tout le
monde se terre regarde ioen regarde le
doigt puis élu non mais qu'est ce que tu
veuilles ou wayne et youenn dans un
sourire dit lolo et ceux ci la veut dire
oh je suis hébergé là que je vois un
enfant quantique monte à tignes était
premier alors pour être compris d'un
jeune enfant et pour mieux le comprendre
mettez vous à sa hauteur
regardez le écoutez le parlez-lui en
face et signa avec lui vous pouvez
commencer par des comptines par exemple
par exemple meunier tu dors vous le
connais tu connais mené du dande bon ben
c'est pas celle là qu'on va faire nous
on va faire une qui fonctionne bien dans
nos ateliers
c'est à huy et chauffeurs si vous voulez
bien on a déjà vu des chansons avant
mais là c'est plus galettes saucisses
schouten c'est petit escargot maison sur
le dos et pour ça on se détend les
doigts parce que les signes développe la
motricité fine de l'enfant et en plus la
coordination à leur compte et prétendit
partie petit cargo porte sur son dos et
sa maisonnette aussitôt qu'il pleut il
est tout
il s'appelle
ouais merci merci à tous